Are you
Hey
darling.
Happy.
Oh.
Now this question is going to become
very important. Jesus
impostor or messiah? It's a very
important question because this Jesus
lays claims to some astounding things.
He says for example,
I am the way, the truth, and the life.
How many come to the father?
>> No one comes to the father except by me.
That's what he says.
And today
this Jesus is being marginalized
and the critics and especially what they
call the new reformation movement is
disseminating the Bible and ripping the
heart out of the messianic side of the
Bible.
Jesus must if we want to have world
unity of religions become one on a level
with all the others. Isn't that right?
>> He cannot stand out above anyone else.
He has to come down to the level of all
the others. But if this Jesus Christ is
the Messiah of God and is God,
well then we are going to come up to an
impass. So let's have a look what the
Bible says because I don't want to
influence you. Jesus impostor or
messiah.
Jesus says in John 6:38,
"For I came down from heaven." Well,
that's not everyone who can say that,
right? That's not something usual. I
can't say that.
So either this is presumption or it is
truth.
evidence that demands a verdict. It's a
book by Joss McDall. He says, "Some
skeptics have suggested that these
prophecies, the prophecies about Jesus
and the messianic prophecies were
accidentally or coincidentally fulfilled
by Jesus. According to the science of
probability, the chance of any one human
being up until recent present,
fulfilling a selection of just eight of
these prophecies, including the one on
the crucifixion, is 1 in 10 to the^ of
17." And here we are considering only
eight prophecies. What if we were to
consider 48 prophecies?
The chance would then become virtually
zero at 1 to the power* 10 to the power
of 157. And you must remember that the
number of particles as decide defined by
science in the entire universe is only
10 to the^ 80. So this is the number of
particles in billions upon billions upon
billions add infinitum
universes. Wow.
What about all 61 prophecies? I believe
there are even more than 61 prophecies.
And every single one of them is
fulfilled by Jesus Christ. Numbers 24:17
says, "There shall come a star out of
Jacob. He would be preceded by a
messenger." I'm just going to run
through a few of them. I'm not going to
even make a big deal out of this. I want
to come to a particular prophecy
tonight. So we'll briefly run through
some of these ancient prophecies. Isaiah
40:3, the voice of him that crith in the
wilderness, prepare ye the way of the
Lord, make straight in the desert a
highway for our God. So the Bible
predicts that he will be preceded, the
Messiah, by a messenger. In those days
came John the Baptist preaching in the
wilderness of Judea and saying, "Repent
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand."
Matthew 3:es 1:3.
So he was preaching this very message
predicted by the Messiah in John 8:36 it
says if the son therefore shall make you
free you shall be free indeed. It's a
very important prophecy. So according to
the statement by Jesus,
freedom comes through Christ and through
no one else because he says no one comes
to the father except by me.
The Jews answered, "We are Abraham's
seed and were never in bondage to any
man. How so thou that we will be made
free?" He was talking of freedom from
bondage, freedom from sin. My kingdom is
not of this world. John 18:36. I mean,
these are astounding claims.
The miraculous birth. Behold, a virgin
shall conceive and bear a son and shall
call his name Emmanuel. God with us. Not
just anyone. God with us. You'll say,
"But he wasn't called Emanuel. He was
called Jesus." Well, you see, in ancient
times, the name referred to something.
It had a meaning. It wasn't just an
objective name. It had a meaning. So,
Emmanuel means God with us. Joshua,
which is translated in the Greek as
Jesus, means Yave the Savior. God the
Savior. And Jesus laid claim to being
God. Therefore, he's not on a par with
anyone
in any religious system.
That's Isaiah 7:14.
And the angel said to her, "You will be
with child and give birth to a son, and
you shall give him the name Jesus."
Which is exactly the same as Emmanuel.
Yahe
the savior is here. In other words, God
with us. Luke 1:28:31.
Then the Old Testament says, "Bethlehem,
Bethlehem,
out of thee shall he come forth unto me
that is to be ruler in Israel." Micah
5:2.
And this particular Bethlehem,
Bethlehem, Bethlehem Epha, which means
the bread basket, the bread of life,
would come down and be born in
Bethlehem. And of course, we know that
that was also fulfilled. Jesus was born
in Bethlehem of Judea in the time of
Herod and he was given the name Joshua
Yave the Savior.
Jesus said, "The Lord has anointed me to
preach good tidings unto the meek." But
this is an Old Testament prophecy as
well. Bind up the brokenhearted to
proclaim liberty to the captives and the
opening of the prison to them that are
bound to proclaim the acceptable year of
the Lord to comfort all that mourn.
Isaiah 61 1-2. So there's a prophecy
that's fulfilled. Luke 4:18
and 19 tell us that that is exactly what
Jesus claimed for himself.
Isaiah proclaims that the Messiah would
work through miracles. Then the eyes of
the blind shall be opened. The ears of
the deaf shall be unstopped. Then shall
the lame man leap like a heart and the
tongue of the dumb shall sing. And the
New Testament, Matthew tells us, Luke
tells us, he went about healing all
manner of diseases to appoint unto them
that mourn in Zion the oil of joy for
mourning the garment of praise for the
spirit of heaviness. Isaiah 61:3.
In the Psalms, we read that the Messiah
would open his mouth in parables. I will
open my mouth in parables. All these
things Jesus spoke in parables.
The Bible predicts a triumphal gentry
and we have it there in Zechariah. Thy
king cometh unto thee just and having
salvation, lowly and riding on an ass.
All these things are predictions in the
Old Testament. My close friend whom I
trusted and shared my bread with has
lifted up his heel against me that he
would be betrayed. Is fulfilled and we
read it in Matthew that Judas the
Scariot did precisely that.
What about this one? Zechariah 11
12 and 13. So they weighed for my price
30 pieces of silver. Even the price that
was paid for this deception
is listed in the Old Testament. And they
took 30 pieces of silver and cast them
to the potter in the house of the Lord.
And that's exactly what they did. They
bought the potter's field because they
wouldn't take the money, which was death
money. Jesus went to the chief priests
and they said to him, "What will you
give me and I will give him unto you?"
And they gave him what? 30 pieces of
silver. And he cast down the pieces of
silver in the temple and departed. And
what did they do? They bought the
potter's field. Every single little
detail. I offered mine back to those who
beat me, my cheeks to those who pulled
out my beard. The sufferings that Jesus
went through, unbelievable.
I did not hide my face from the mocking
and spitting. He was tried seven times.
Seven times. Once by Anas. And he was
struck in the face right there. Kaiapas
and Anus. The night trial, the morning
trial, the the trials with the Roman
officials. Then he was sent to Herod,
back to Pilate. Seven times he was
tried.
I did not hide my face from mocking and
spitting. Isaiah 50:6.
They spit in my face. They buffeted him,
smote him with palms. They said, and the
Bible says, they hit him over the head
again and again and again. They hate me
without cause. Psalm 69, that he would
be rejected. Predicted in the Bible,
they hated me without cause. John, he
was oppressed and was afflicted. He
opened not his mouth. He brought was
brought like a lamb to the slaughter.
Everything there in the Old Testament.
The Old Testament is a testimony to
Jesus Christ. And when he was accused of
the chief priests and the elders, he
answered nothing. Just like a lamb to
the slaughter. Matthew 27:12. And they
wagged their heads. They shook their
heads and say, "Look at this guy.
Where's he come from?" Matthew 27.
wagging their heads. Even the way he
would die. Psalms 22:16, "They pierced
my hands and my feet. They crucified
him. He was numbered with
transgressors." Isaiah 53:12. Do you
know that there are Protestant Christian
groups in the world that deny prophecy
totally even denying that the prophecies
here mentioned pertain to Christ when
the New Testament itself applies them to
Jesus Christ. Unbelievable that there
would be Protestant denominations that
do that.
They gave him vinegar to drink. Psalm
69:21, Matthew 27:34,
were crucified with thieves. You know
that that was the case. Mark 15,
Zechariah, they will look on me, the one
they have pierced,
even the way of the crucifixion.
And he bare the sins of many and made
intercession for the transgressors.
Isaiah 53:12.
Beautiful prophecies in the Old
Testament about Jesus. Luke 23:34,
"Father, forgive them for they know not
what they do." Every single aspect about
the Messiah was predicted and is
fulfilled in Jesus Christ. They divided
my garments amongst them and for my
clothing they cost lots. Old Testament
Psalms 22:18. We could go on and on and
on. You know that they divided his
garments, but they cast lot for the
white inner garment. Why? Because it had
no seam. And there's a typology in that.
The righteousness of Christ has no seam.
It is perfect.
It was too perfect to divide. So they
cast lots for it. Beautiful typology
there. John chapter 19.
People say, "Why did he say then, my
God, my God, why did thou forsake me?"
Because it was predicted in Psalms 22:1.
Jesus died the death of total separation
for you and for me. They pierced my
hands and my feet. Psalms 22:16.
Even to down to that detail, the
predictions are there. Psalms 31 verse5
the last words that he would speak into
thy hands I commit my spirit father into
thy hands I commit my spirit everything
there in the old testament he keeps all
his bones not one of them is broken
Psalms 34:20 that was already a typology
with a lamb with a Passover lamb it was
to be eaten but not a bone was to be
broken why because the Messiah's bones
would not be broken
It was the preparation and the Jews were
afraid that they would come down and run
away and they didn't want to chase after
them on the Sabbath day because they had
hordes and hordes of rules written in
their Talmud.
And so they gave the order that they
should break the legs. That's what the
New Testament says. But when they came
to Jesus, he was already dead. So they
did not break his legs. Fulfilling the
prophecy. John 19:32:33.
and they pierced his side.
So the place of his birth is predicted.
The manner of his birth is predicted.
His betrayal is predicted. And the
manner of his death is predicted in
great detail. We've just flown over
them. We haven't even gone into the
detail, the nuances, the finer details.
Absolutely astounding.
Here's a beautiful statement. Christ was
treated as we deserve that we might be
treated as he deserves. He was condemned
for our sins in which he had no share
that we might be justified by his
righteousness in which we had no share.
He suffered the death which was ours
that we might receive the life which was
his. With his stripes we are healed.
Beautiful statement. God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth him should not
perish but have everlasting life. Isaiah
53 again says his grave would be with a
wicked.
Very interesting. And that with a rich
in his death. So he died with a wicked
and a rich man gave him the grave. And
Matthew 27:57
and 60 confirms that very statement. So,
the manner of his death, the way he was
buried, everything there in the Old
Testament. Some of the critics said,
"Well, hang on a second. Maybe he wasn't
a historic figure figure after all.
Maybe the New Testament writers just
wrote all that stuff down to make it
look as if Jesus fulfilled the
prophecies." Now, I hope you realize
that the scribes and the Pharisees never
understood the prophecies because
otherwise they would have accepted the
Messiah, right?
So here we have a story that all these
things were changed and they said that
the individuals involved like Pilate
weren't historic figures. Well, I have
news for them because here was a plaque
that was found. It's on display at a
museum in in Israel where the very names
Tiberius and Pontio Pilatus
are there. Historic figures. Let's have
a look at some of the historians.
Tacitus the Roman historian who lived AD
1115 speaks about Nero's persecution of
the Christians of the year AD46 and he
says Christos from whom their name is
derived was executed at the hands of the
procurator Pontius Pilate in the reign
of Tiberius. So there's an extra
biblical source which says when these
things happened. Then you have Satonius
the Roman historian writing about AD20
and he says since the Jews were
continually making disturbances remember
that the Christians were counted as a
Jewish sect so they were called Jews
disturbances at the instigation of
Christos he Claudius expelled them from
Rome and the Talmud which is the Jewish
traditions said on the eve of the
Passover they hang Yeshu of Nazareth. So
there are sources outside the scriptures
which confirm the very issue. Jesus
Christ was always central. The Messiah
was always central to the religion of
Israel. If you look at the sanctuary
that had to be built, every single item,
every single
practice that occurred within this
sanctuary is a reference to Christ. The
most beautiful story of the plan of
salvation is enacted here in the
sacrifice of the lamb which stood for
the lamb that would take away the sins
of the world. If you go on into the
sanctuary, there was the labor of
washing where you are washed by the
consequences of your action of
confessing your sins. Jesus Christ, the
light of the world. Jesus Christ the
bread of life. Jesus Christ the
intercessor. Jesus Christ the mercy.
Everything is there. It's a beautiful
story. We haven't got time into it. Even
in the typology of the high priest, the
high priest stood for Jesus Christ. He
was a type because Paul says we have
such a high priest. Jesus Christ the one
who entered into the majesty of heaven.
Hebrews 8 verse 1 and 2. We have such a
high priest who is set on the right hand
of the throne of majesty in heaven, a
minister of the sanctuary of the true
tabernacle which the Lord pitched and
not man. Very interesting stuff. For
Christ not entered the holy places made
with hands which are the figure of the
true. So that was the figure of the real
thing. This was just a type now to
appear in the presence of God for us. He
entered into heaven itself. Hebrews 9:4.
The whole Old Testament was a typology
of the very acts of Jesus. So now we are
faced with a problem. The world is going
to expect very soon that everybody
acknowledges equality of all.
But the Bible says there's only one way
to salvation and that is through Jesus
Christ.
and that Jesus was not one of many
prophets in this world, but that he was
the predicted Messiah, the God man, the
one who would come down from heaven to
pay the price for sin, for your
salvation. And we have to know where we
stand. Well, there's a fantastic
prophecy in Daniel which has put this
issue beyond a shadow of doubt. So much
so that it is a nightmare
for those who want to reject Jesus
Christ as the Messiah. In Daniel chapter
8, we have also a flow through history
like we did in Daniel chapter 2. Now
when we did the head and the and the
arms of silver and the bronze and the
iron, but here the whole issue is
repeated in terms of animals. And you
have here a particular goat with two
horns, one larger than the other. And
the Bible tells us who it is. We don't
have to guess. It's a reference to the
Mes and the Persians.
And it tells us that while these horns
were there, another goat came along with
a prominent horn between his eyes. And
we again, we don't have to guess. In
Daniel chapter 8, it tells us who the
horn is. A horn is a king or a kingdom.
It says the prominent horn between his
eyes is the first king of Greece. So,
who was it?
>> Alexander the Great. We don't have to
guess. The Bible tells us exactly what
these symbols stand for. And he says he
approached and he attacked the twohorned
one and broke off the horns. Meo Persia
was conquered. So there he comes flying,
crashes into the other one, breaks off
his horns. And Daniel 8:8 says,
"Therefore the goat waxed very great.
And when he was strong, the great horn
was broken." So Alexander the Great
would come to his end and in its place
four notable ones would come up towards
the winds of heaven and we know that
Greece was divided into four regions.
Interesting. There were 12 generals
fighting over it. But after those
battles there were just four regions.
And out of one of them came forth a
little horn which waxed exceeding great
towards the south and towards the east
and towards the pleasant land. And it
waxed great even to the host of heaven.
And it cast down some of the host of the
stars to the ground and stamped upon it.
Yet it magnified himself even to the
prince of host
and by him the daily sacrifice is there
written cursively. So it wasn't in the
original text. That's what it means in
the King King James version. When they
write it cursively, it means it's not in
the original. So by him the daily was
taken away and the place of his
sanctuary was cast down. Now this whole
sanctuary stood for the Messiah and Rome
came along and crucified the Messiah.
Now we'll deal with this in some detail
a little later on. Then I heard one
saint, now he's in vision, and he's
hearing an angel speak to another one
speaking. And another saint said unto
that certain saint which spake,
how long shall be the vision concerning
the daily
sacrifice? Added by the way, the daily,
which is the tamid. The tamid is the
continual. That was that fire that was
burning when they looked at it. The fire
meant that the sacrifice
was always available. The atonement of
Christ. We can come to that in a later
lecture. And the transgression of
desolation to give both the sanctuary
and the host to be trotten underfoot.
And he said unto me, and now we have a
time prophecy,
unto 2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed. Daniel 8:13 and 14. We have a
time prophecy. Now, we're not going to
deal with this prophecy tonight, this
2,300
day prophecy. We'll deal with it in
another evening in detail. So, I don't
want to go into this into detail, but he
is discussing a particular time
prophecy. And I want you to look at a
portion of this time prophecy. Daniel
8:23:26.
And in the latter time of their kingdom,
a king of fierce countenance and
understanding, dark sentences shall
stand up. He shall also stand up against
the prince of princes, but he shall be
broken without hand. There you have the
without hand again. Thunderous prophecy.
We're going to deal with it and we're
going to see who's going to be in
control just before Christ comes. And
the vision of the evening and the
morning which was told is true.
Therefore, shut up the vision, for it is
for many days for the future.
He said unto me, unto 2,300 days, then
shall the sanctuary be cleansed. So,
here is a a vision that Daniel is given,
and he doesn't understand it. Doesn't
understand it at all. And he's told,
don't worry, you don't have to
understand it. It concerns the distant
future, and it will be unsealed at a
later stage, but not now. And we're not
going to deal with this in this lecture.
In another lecture, we'll come to it.
So he's thinking about this vision. He
doesn't understand it. So here he's
standing. Daniel 8:17. So he came near
where I stood and when he came I was
afraid and fell on my face. So he's in
vision
and he sees this heavenly being falls on
his face. Understand, oh son of man, for
at the time of the end shall be the
vision. So the vision concerns the
future, concerns the time of the end.
And it has so many aspects to it that
bother Daniel. And then in Daniel
chapter 9 from vers 20 onwards, we have
an explanation of part of the vision. So
while I was speaking in prayer, the man
Gabriel, this is the the angel Gabriel
came to me in swift flight and he said
to me, "Oh Daniel, I have now come out
to give you wisdom and understanding."
So now he's going to explain something
to him and we want to know what it's
about. And here we go. Fasten your seat
belts.
70 weeks are determined upon thy people
and upon thy holy city. How many days in
a week?
>> 70.
>> Seven. So 70 weeks would be 70* 7. We'll
come to that. Days. So 70 weeks are
determined upon thy people, that's the
Jews,
and upon thy holy city, which one is
that? Jerusalem
to finish transgression, to make an end
of sins, to make reconciliation for
iniquity, to bring in everlasting
righteousness, to seal up the vision and
the prophecy, and to anoint the most
holy. Daniel 9 verse 24. Thunderous
vision. Thunderous prophecy. So 70 weeks
are determined cut off
for this particular time from this
particular time period and all these
things must be accomplished. End of
sins, reconciliation for iniquity, bring
in everlasting righteousness.
Now who did all that?
Who brings in everlasting righteousness?
Who can make an end to sin?
Only Jesus.
This is a messianic prophecy. Now, let
me tell you, the Jews are very upset
about this prophecy.
Listen to this. This is the rebanic
curse. The rebanic curse. And you will
find it in Talmudic Law, page 978,
section 2, line 28. Let me read it to
you. May the bones of the hands and the
bones of the fingers decay and decompose
of him who turns the pages of the book
of Daniel to find out the time of Daniel
9:24-27.
And may his memory rot from off the face
of the earth forever.
Wow. These guys mean business.
Would you agree?
So now I have to ask you something. Or
what did Americans say? Ask you
something.
Are you willing to go on in spite of
that curse?
Because if you are going to number with
me Daniel 9:24-27,
then this curse should theoretically
stick to us. But let me tell you
something. I serve someone greater than
this curse.
>> I have no fear of this curse.
>> And I know why they've got this curse.
Because if this curse were not there,
somebody might number that prophecy and
find out whom they really should serve.
Let's see.
Cut off, determined, separated from
70 weeks cut off from the bigger
prophecy for the Jews. Now, let's look a
look at it. In prophecy,
a day
counts for a year. A week counts
therefore for seven days. So a day for
the year, the dayear principle means
that it counts for seven years. Now can
I say that just by myself?
>> Nope. That would be arrogance. So let's
get some biblical support. Ezekiel
4:6, I have pointed thee each day for a
year. Talking about a prophetic sense.
or numbers 14:34 after the number of
days in which you search the land even
40 days each day for a year. So now the
proof of the pudding is always in the
eating. Let's apply apply the day year
principle and number the 70 weeks and
see where we get.
70 weeks are appointed
on your people. 70 weeks well a week has
seven days. So how many days is that?
That's 490 days. And that is therefore
490 prophetic years which are cut off.
Cut off from what?
Obviously the 2,300 day prophecy which
he was talking about. So that would
bring us to 2,300 years. 490 years cut
off for the Jews. That's what it means.
All right, let's have a look a little
further.
Then the sanctuary would be cleansed at
the end of that period. Now, I'm going
to deal with only this part of the
prophecy tonight. Only this 70 week. In
order to find out what this is about, we
have to know when the prophecy starts,
right? So, when do these 2,300
years begin?
From when do we start counting the 70
weeks which the rabbitic code says we're
not allowed to study?
Well, Daniel 9:4 gives us the answer.
There's a curse upon this verse.
Interesting. That rabbis should curse a
part of Daniel. Does that puzzle you
tonight?
It would certainly puzzle me if I were
you because it puzzled me like crazy.
70 weeks are determined upon thy people.
Know therefore and understand that from
the going forth of the commandment to
restore and rebuild Jerusalem unto what?
>> Unto the Messiah.
So from the going forth of the decree to
restore and rebuild Jerusalem. Remember
Daniel is in captivity. Jerusalem is
destroyed. And now he's tiled 70 weeks.
And you start counting when
from the time when the decree goes forth
from the going forth of the decree, the
commandment to restore and build
Jerusalem unto the Messiah the prince
shall be seven weeks and three score and
two weeks. And the streets shall be
built again, and the wall even in
troubles times. 9:25.
Wow.
He just received a messianic prophecy
telling Daniel precisely when the
Messiah would come.
Did you know that it's in the Bible? Did
you know that? Well, let's work it out.
7 weeks,
49 days, 49 years. 62 weeks, 434 days,
years. Where does that bring us? The
decree to restore and build Jerusalem
and then there would be seven weeks
temple restored and then Messiah the
prince.
So what do we need? We need a date over
here and we can work it out. Is that
right? We need a date. Ada Sexus, king
of Persia, issued the decree in the year
BC. This decree was total political
freedom again for the Jews. There was a
Cyrus decree previously which pertained
only to the temple. But this decree, our
dyslexus 457 BC pertains to the
restoration
of Jerusalem. There we go. So we have a
starting date. So 457
plus 483, that's the 49 plus the 48 uh
434 brings us to the year AD27.
And what happened in AD 27 69 weeks 43
one day for a year I've appointed you a
day for a year remember day for a year
and let's look at the decree Ezra 7:12
and 13 unto sex as king of kings unto
Ezra the priest the scribe of the law of
God of heaven I make a decree that all
they which of the people of Israel which
are minded of their own free will to go
up to Jerusalem go with thee that was
the decree and I at the sexist kingdom
make a decree to all the treasurers that
are beyond the river that whatever Ezra
the priest shall require of you, it be
done speedily. Ezra 7:21. And by the
way, a archaeological tablet has been
found confirming the date 457 BC. So
it's beyond the shadow of doubt. There
can be no argument about the date. It's
found written in stone.
457 490 years. The total prophecy is
2,300 years. Know therefore and
understand that from the going forth of
the commandment to rebuild unto the
Messiah the prince there shall be seven
weeks and 62 weeks. Now 7 + 62 is how
much?
That's 69 weeks. The total prophecy
concerns how many weeks?
>> 70. So there's another week to go. But
the prophecy says that Messiah which
means anointed one will come after the
69 weeks and that worked out to which
year do you remember 20
>> 7 A D. So the decree went out 457
69 * 7 430 83 days
and total restoration that was only that
particular decree unto the Messiah. So
27 AD the Messiah. Now how old was Jesus
when he started his messianic ministry?
>> He was 30. Now why 27 AD? Here's a
problem. 30 and 27, they don't add up.
Ah, but go to any little encyclopedia,
even a children's encyclopedia,
and you will see that our
time has been shifted
and that the whole period is really out
by these four years. You don't count the
zero year. and that Jesus was actually
30 in the year 27 AD. The word Messiah
means anointed one. And when Jesus was
anointed,
that happened at his baptism. Now, in
the 15th year of the reign of Tiberius,
Caesar, this is quoting the scriptures.
When all the peoples were baptized, it
came to pass that Jesus also being
baptized and praying to heaven, praying
the heaven was opened.
Luke 3 1 and 21. Now that year of
Tiberius was 27 AD. Now,
how many messiahs can there be?
>> Only one.
only one that fulfills every single
prophecy. The 15th year of Tiberius
Caesar was 27 AD and Jesus was anointed
with the Holy Spirit precisely on time.
Now, can you imagine now why the re
rabbitical Talmud said, "Cursed be the
one who numbers the 70 weeks." Because
Judaism
would come to an end if they accepted
what Daniel said. Judaism would come to
an end.
And the Holy Ghost descended in a bodily
shape like a dove upon him. And a voice
came from heaven which says, "Thou art
my beloved son. In thee I am well
pleased."
Now listen to what it says in Mark 1
verse1 15.
Jesus was just anointed. The year was 27
AD. And he says, "And saying, the time
is fulfilled, and the kingdom of God is
at hand. Repent thee and believe the
gospel." Mark 1:15. Which time is
fulfilled?
Which time is fulfilled? John 1:29.
Behold the lamb of God which taketh away
the sins of the world. The anointed one,
the Messiah. Was he there? God anointed
Jesus of Nazareth with the Holy Ghost
and with power. Acts 10:38. That took
place at his baptism.
So the going forth of the Messiah who
would take the sins of the world upon
him was predicted precisely in the
Bible. The date Galatians 4:4 says,
"When the fullness of time was come, God
sent forth his son." Which fullness of
time?
There was a prophecy that had to be
fulfilled and only Jesus fulfills it.
Nobody else. And I'm going to put it
straight out to you. Nobody else. No
Shiva, no Brahma, no Vishna, no Buddha,
no Muhammad, no nobody. Jesus
>> fulfilled it. No one else.
So there is only one biblical Messiah
and no one comes to the father except
through him.
>> Now I was giving a lecture in Germany
and I said that and somebody got up in
the audience and said to me but that's
arrogance.
How can you say that nobody comes to the
father except through Jesus Christ?
That's arrogance. What about all the
others?
And I said, "Yeah, you're right. It
sounds arrogant
to say,"Nobody does it except through
this one particular individual. But if
somebody comes up to me and he says to
me, and I'm sitting there with my
daughter, and he says to me, "Are you
the father of that child?" And I say,
"Yep, I'm the father of that child." And
he says to me, "Hey, out of all the
billions of people of this planet, you
say you're the father." That's
arrogance.
Well, you know, folks, that might be
arrogance, but it could also just be a
fact,
right?
>> Although my sister does say that
fatherhood is an opinion and motherhood
is a fact.
So we could perhaps argue the issue, but
the fact of the matter, the point that
I'm making is if there Jesus is the
Messiah and if Jesus is Emmanuel, if
Jesus is the Joshua, the Yave, the
savior, then no one else qualifies,
right or wrong?
>> And if he is the creator, there's no one
else, right?
>> So can I accept the hodgepodge?
>> No.
>> Or must I make a choice?
What if I am told to bow down to someone
else?
Well, I have interesting news. In my
country, in South Africa, they're
bringing out new laws and new curricula.
And these are going to be filtered
throughout the whole world. The whole
world is going to get them. And in our
school system, we have something called
curriculum 2005,
which means that in the future, our
children must be trained in all
religions, say all the prayers of all
the other religions, and acknowledge the
deities of all the other religions as
well. I have a problem with that. So
soon, I don't know, maybe there'll be
this image, and I'll have to say, well,
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I I can't go along with that.
When the fullness of time was come, God
sent forth his son. Galatians 4:4.
And what happens in the 70th week? You
know, there are people that now there
are many prophetic ways that are out
there in the world. And some take this
70th week and they throw it into the
future somewhere way out there. And they
say that pertains to the Antichrist.
Now hang on a second. The 70 weeks
pertain to the Jews to end transgression
to bring in ever righteous everlasting
righteousness. All of it was messianic.
All of it was messianic. After three
scores and two weeks
shall Messiah be what does it say there?
>> Cut off but not for himself. What does
that mean? He will die but not for
himself. For whom?
>> For us.
Now it's current. It gets exciting. It
gets thunderously exciting. And the
people of the prince that shall come
shall destroy the city. Now we have a
kayazm, a beautiful kayazm talking about
two forces at work. Messiah the prince
and another one who comes and destroys
the city. Who is he?
It was the Rome. Rome came and destroyed
the city AD70.
So Messiah will shall be cut off, but
not for himself. And the people of the
prince that shall come shall destroy the
city and the sanctuary, and the end of
shall be with a flood, and the end of
the war desolations are determined.
Daniel 9 26.
Then he
shall confirm a covenant with many for
one week. This is now
Messiah,
the other ruler, Messiah. That's how the
kayazm works. So the Messiah will
confirm the covenant with many for one
week. But now note this. In the middle
of the week, he shall bring an end to
sacrifice and offering.
Wow.
How did the Messiah bring an end to the
sacrificial system?
>> He was the sacrifice.
>> He became the sacrifice.
He became the sacrifice. So now we have
the 70th week. Now folks, please think
about this.
The 70th week pertains still to the
Messiah. That cannot be thrown into the
future because in the middle of that
week, by the way, the middle of seven is
how much?
>> And how long was Jesus
active after his anointing?
>> Three and a half years. And in the
middle of that week, he was cut off, but
not for you and me. And he brought an
end to the sacrificial system because he
became the lamb of God that take away
the sins of the world. Is that right? So
only he can fulfill this part of the
prophecy. Therefore, can I throw it into
the future or does it pertain to the
time of Christ?
>> It pertains to the time of Christ. He
shall bring an end to sacrifice and
offering. There is one prophetic week or
seven literal years left in the
prophecy.
What is a half of seven? Three and a
half. 3 and 1/2 years from the fall of
27 AD leads us to the spring of 31 AD.
So we have 27 3 and a2
and the sacrificial system of the Jews
which the temple stood for comes to an
end. Shall Messiah be cut off but not
for himself. It's phenomenal. This
ancient prophecy points to Jesus and to
no one else. Much to the disgust of many
religious leaders in the world today.
70th week, 31 AD, Jesus dies, but
there's still a three and a half left.
70 weeks were determined upon the Jews.
What happened in 34 AD? Now, let me tell
you something. Jesus said to the Jews,
to these disciples,
"Go ye first to the lost children of
what?"
>> Israel. "Go ye first to the lost
children of Israel." He didn't reject
them even at his death. He said, "Go ye
first to the children, lost children of
Israel."
And they worked amongst the Jews. But
then in 34 AD, something happened.
Something happened. They stoned Steven.
They stoned Steven and the Christians
fled. And who persecuted them? Who was
sent after them? You remember?
>> Paul. And Paul received a vision. And he
was made the apostle to whom?
>> The Gentiles. Aha. Peter receives a
vision of a sheet coming down filled
with unclean things. And he's sent to
Cornelius, a gentile.
And he comes to Cornelius and he says,
"God has shown me in vision that I must
not call any man unclean or impure."
You know, he says to him that it is
unlawful for a Jew to associate with a
gentile, but God has shown me in vision.
I can come to you. So AD34,
Steven is stoned.
The commission that the gospel would be
carried forth by the Jews comes to an
end and the Gentiles take the message
further. They preach the risen Christ.
Isn't that interesting?
And any Jew that wants to be grafted
into the vine can be grafted in, but he
has to acknowledge Jesus Christ as his
personal savior and therefore become a
Christian. And if you be in Christ, then
you be Abraham's seed.
>> That's how it works. Christ was
crucified exactly on time according to
the prophecy, exactly as the prophecy
foretold it would happen. And in the
middle of the week, he was crucified.
But still,
mercy lingered until they totally
rejected not only Christ, but his
followers as well. According to the
prophecy of Daniel's, God covenant with
the Jews would cease 34 AD. And
henceforth you have to be grafted into
the vine. They preached
and they were rejected.
Here at the sheep's gates, this is where
they brought him up where they crucified
the Savior. They wanted him as their
king of kings and they wanted him to
destroy the Romans, but he came to
destroy sin.
Yet it was I who taught Aframe to walk.
I took them up in my arms, but they did
not know that I had healed them. Hosea
11:3. I led them with cords of
compassion, with bands of love, and I
bent down to them and fed them. How can
I give you up, O Ephraim? How can I hand
you over, O Israel? Jerusalem,
Jerusalem, how often I wanted to gather
you under my wings like a mother ha
chicks, but you would. Not. Therefore,
your house is left to you desolate.
The time when they would be the carriers
of the gospel message would come to an
end. As he approached Jerusalem, he saw
the city and he wept. He wept. If you
even you had known on this day what
would bring you peace, but now it is
hidden from your eyes. Why? Because of
the hardness of their hearts. The days
will come upon when when your enemies
will build an embankment against you and
encircle you and hem you in on every
side and they will dash you to the
ground and your children within the
walls and they will not leave one stone
upon another. Luke 19. Was it fulfilled?
>> Yes.
Look, your house is left to you
desolate. So the gospel is carried to
the by the Gentiles. By the way, what
does desolate mean? Does it mean there's
something left or there's no light?
>> Nothing. Nothing at all. Nothing at all.
In the midst of the week, Christ the
Messiah would cause the sacrifice to
cease. These verses tell that the
Messiah would die by crucifixion on the
14th day of the first Jewish month in
the year AD31.
And every single detail has been
fulfilled by Jesus Christ. Now notice,
the Bible says in Mark 15:38, "And the
veil of the temple was rent in twain
from the top to the bottom." Not from
the bottom to the top. Uh-uh. From the
top to the bottom. Who rent it?
>> God. He tore it. Now when that veil tore
then the way to the most holy was open
which meant any Jew could look into the
most holy and live.
Wow. Why? Because the sacrificial system
had come to an end. Now think about
this.
Jesus fulfilled the sacrificial system.
Yes or no?
>> Because by one sacrifice he has forever
made perfect. one sacrifice. What if I
was to build a little temple and start
sacrificing again? What would I be
saying if I did that?
>> That Christ was not sacrificed and did
not fulfill everything.
So if they want to build another temple,
let them do it. But it is not from God.
>> Amen.
>> Are you with me on this or not?
>> So the veil of the temple was rent in
twain from top to bottom. Behold, the
curtain of the temple was torn in two
from top to bottom. Matthew 27:51. God
saw to it that it is written down for
us. So, according to the prophecies of
Daniel, God's covenant with the Jews
would cease AD 34 at the end of the 70
weeks. And you cannot throw the 70th
week into the future because the
sacrificial system was ended by Jesus
himself. So, it fits back into the past.
AD34 the stoning of Steven the Jewish
leaders reject the gospel and it goes to
the Gentiles. Galatians 3 29 if you
belong to Christ
then you are Abraham's seed and hes
according to the promise.
So in other words everyone who accepts
Jesus Christ is Abraham's seed. Yes or
no? Because Paul says the seed refers to
the singular which means that the refers
to Jesus Christ and to nothing else.
Neither circumcision nor uncircumcision
means anything. What counts is a new
creation. Peace and mercy to all who
follow this rule. Even the Israel of
God. Who's that?
>> Christians.
>> The ones who accept Christ. That's who
it is.
So, I love the Jews and I have many
Jewish friends
and I really pray with all my heart that
they will accept the gospel. And I hope
there are many Jews here tonight. I'm
not hammering the Jews here tonight. I'm
discussing a prophecy, a prophecy that
points to Jesus.
And he said unto them, "Unto 2,300 days,
then shall the sanctuary be cleansed."
There's more to this prophecy, more to
it. The cleansing of the sanctuary is a
Jewish feast, and we'll have to look at
it. It was the day of judgment, so it
refers to judgment day at the end of
time.
End of the world. The prophecy will end
2,300 days later, and then will come
eternity. We all know that this earth
was judged once before and destroyed by
a flood. And everybody who wasn't in the
ark drowned. And in the same way, search
the scriptures, for in them you think
you have eternal life, but they are they
which testify of me. John 5:39.
In Jesus we have life. In Jesus we have
saved. In Jesus, we can go through to
the kingdom in no one else. And if we
understand this prophecy, then we cannot
be duped by what is coming upon the
world. And I want to warn the people of
this country and all the countries of
the world that this showdown is soon to
take place. Serve the Lord and nobody
will be lost. Thank you for coming.
Hey,
I want to do
Hey
oh.
Oh,
glory.
hey.
Oh,
go.
Hey. Hey.